ok katja guten abend dort in deutschland
wo bist du jetzt können wir können auch
dazu möchte ja natürlich war uns bewusst
ich wohne in deutschland das heißt wenn
jedes ist gerade abend halb sieben in
deutschland kann ich fragen wohin und in
süddeutschland in baden württemberg ok
und du hast ein kanal aber ich glaube es
würde besseren du dich selbst dich
selbst vorstellen ja gerne
naja also mein name ist katja ich
unterrichte deutsch auf youtube auf
einem kanal namens deutsch für euch den
ich 2013 aufgebaut habe und dort mache
ich seit dem ganz viele videos über das
deutsch lernen
besonders gerne mache ich videos über
grammatik aber auch videos über
wortschatz ganz viel hörverstehen habe
ich mittlerweile auch und was leute
interessiert ja genau
okay okay dann ich möchte fragen ich wir
haben auch in lync haben die leute die
deutschlehrerin und manchmal höre ich
von deute leute die deutsch lernen sie
sollen ja ich war nach deutschland
gefahren und niemand hat mich deutsch
gesprochen ich habe egal 1 geschafft ich
habe was gefragt und die antwort immer
auf englisch was sagst was sagst du das
hier ja das ist eine beschwerde die ich
auch kenne ich glaube das ist sogar eine
so häufige beschwerde dass sich darüber
sogar schon einmal einen web comic
gesehen habe von jemandem der
deutschland zu besuch war
ich glaube dass das vor allem in städten
stimmt auf dem land weiß ich nicht wenn
man pech hat da trifft man vielleicht
auch mal jemanden der jetzt dringend
englisch üben will aber normalerweise
passiert einem das natürlich in der
stadt
das liegt glaube ich erstens daran dass
tatsächlich viele leute in deutschland
gut englisch sprechen und dann denken
okay das ist offensichtlich jemand der
irgendwo aus dem ausland kommt
und auf englisch geht es vielleicht
schneller und ja ich habe auch den
eindruck dass viele deutsche so ein
bisschen zurückhaltend sind also sie
wollen sie wollen vielleicht den
ausländern oder den touristen nicht
deutsch aufdrängen
das ist irgendwie süß weil natürlich
wenn ich hier als besucher auf deutsch
jemanden anspreche dann denke ich
natürlich warum spricht ja nicht deutsch
mit mir aber ihr müsst ein bisschen
verständnis mit uns haben dass wir
manchmal denken wir sind sehr effizient
das klischee stimmt manchmal dass wir
denken englisch geht einfach schneller
und dass uns der andere einen gefallen
damit tut dass er englisch mit uns
steuer deutsch mit uns spricht das heißt
ich glaube es ist fast mehr ein
entgegenkommen und auch dieses schöne
wort für das es keine wirklich schöne
deutsche übersetzung gibt witness aber
wenn man den leuten sagt nein sagen sie
es bitte auf deutsch ich möchte deutsch
sprechen
dann hören die meisten leute auch darauf
das darf man ruhig sagen das ist nicht
unhöflich das ist okay ihr dürft ruhig
so selbstbewusstsein und auch sagen ich
brauche ein bisschen länger ich kann
nicht so gut deutsch aber ich möchte
üben und das werden die leute auch
respektieren also es liegt nicht daran
dass er deutsch so schlecht ist dass die
leute sagen mit dir rede ich kein
deutsch
es ist mehr höflichkeit voraus greifen
die höflichkeit zu höflich ja ja ich
finde man also ist nicht jeder jede
serie geht nicht dann ein
doch ich lehrer seien sie hat arbeit zu
machen
andere kunden deswegen ich glaube außer
man kann nur auf deutsch voraussetzen ja
und dann dann werde die leute
wahrscheinlich oder auf englisch
fortsetzung oder auf deutsch antworten
aber ich es ist also spargelernte ist
wegen also kommunizieren und das ist das
hauptziel und man kann nicht erwarten
dass sie leute werde wie ein lehrer mit
dir auch durch baken es ist es kann sein
oder nichtsein und auch ich glaube es
ist auch eine frage wie gut spricht dann
doch ja wäre wenn du schlecht wenn du
hast eine sehr schlechte wo auch durch
die leute werden auf englisch warnt vor
es kann doch nicht gut genug gut genug
dann werden sie auch auf deutsch
das ist komisch und das ist nicht das
glaub ich ok alle frage warum werden die
leute deutsch ich weiß wir haben außer
englisch ist das okay internationale
sprache der idee haben wie ich leute
lernen japanisch wegen anime oder oder
es gibt verschiedene dinge also spannend
ich weder werden weil sie sonst
warum lernen also deutsch
das ist eine sehr gute frage die ich
auch nicht selber lange gefragt habe
weil es gibt die langweiligen gründe das
weiß ich nicht jemand in einer firma
arbeitet die ihr mit deutschland
kooperiert oder so was aber sagen wir
mal leute die als hobby deutsch lernen
oder einfach weil es sie interessiert
ich glaube die größten gründe sind immer
egal bei welcher sprache popkultur und
zum beispiel deutsche musik
wir haben auf einem kanal zum beispiel
kurz rammstein angesprochen also ein es
gibt bestimmte deutsche künstler musik
bands die international bekannt geworden
sind und ja was mich selber überrascht
hat ist das deutsch irgendwie so einen
neuen coolness-faktor erreicht hat ich
war zum beispiel als ich in russland war
sagte mir ein mädchen aus frankreich
dass deutschland in frankreich jetzt hip
wäre was ich von frankreich niemals
gewünscht hätte um ehrlich zu sein ich
glaube gerade berlin zieht viele leute
viele junge leute an es gibt sehr viel
kunst kultur eine uni
das ist auch ein grund dass leute
angehören
die ja sehr viele leute auch es ist eine
riesige stadt genau sind dann gibt es
natürlich auch den grund dass leute
vielleicht hier studieren möchten weil
es gute universitäten gibt und mal ganz
abgesehen davon gibt es natürlich auch
viele leute die schon nach deutschland
gezogen sind und jetzt läuft deutsch
lernen wollen
aber ich glaube im ausland auch gerade
in den usa da gibt es vielleicht auch
leute mit oder gibt es immer wieder
leute mit deutschen wurzeln die
vielleicht mit ihren großeltern auf
deutsch reden möchten oder einfach ihre
ihre ja ihre wurzeln wiederfinden aber
ich glaube alles in allem die bei jeder
sprache wie auch bei japanisch mit anime
läuft sehr viel über popkultur über
medien über bücher musik oder auch das
internet also youtube also ich möchte
gern mein deutsch verbessern ich habe
ganz viel vergessen ich war in die
neunziger jahre habe ich ganz viel
geschäfte gemacht
auf der autobahn mit meiner
sehr viel deutsch gesprochen aber jetzt
nicht verwende sehr wenig leute aber ich
habe sehr gern die deutsche sprache ich
finde diese sowie mark twain hat gesagt
die idee diese lange lange hälse ohne
aber ich finde das sehr schön also das
ist also jede sprache die ich lerne ich
habe gern die weise die chemikalie weise
die jede sprache hat sich zu ihr sagt
max raster ist die dinge zu sagen dinge
auszudrücken auszudrücken und drücken
und und ich habe das ja es klingt sehr
schön für mich und der deutsch also die
deutsche sprache also ich sehr schön in
deutschland zu reisen
nicht nur die hose städte aber auch
dieser kleine dörfer sehr schön ich war
was heißt dass rosenheim in bayern das
ist so einer hauptstadt für die
holzindustrie und dinkelsbühl ich war
auf den dinkel und also es ist es ist
sehr schön und auch geschichte weil
natürlich in die deutsche in die
europäische geschichte der platz
deutschland ist der wichtige martin
luther hat aber nicht nur von anfangs
habe meine mama hat deutsch geworden
ich weiß ein früher frühere oder in rot
oder zum beispiel wurde historisch ja
auch sehr viel deutsch gesprochen also
das stimmt dass es auch noch einen einen
aspekt also ich kenne zum beispiel um
umgekehrt leute die sehr an geschichte
interessiert sind die deswegen interesse
an russland oder frankreich haben es
kann gut sein dass man bei manchen
leuten auch eine rolle spielt ja ja ja
so für mich ist das immer italienisch
spanisch deutsch russisch chinesisch
japanisch ist für mich ist es immer
mit die geschichte von düffel und ich
habe zu hause habe ich ganz viele
hörbücher auf deutsch
golo mann spricht über deutsche
geschichte
also ich habe auch literatur habe ich
gehört er sich mein deutsch habe ich
durch sehr viel hören und lesen ein
bisschen verbessert aber ich habe
nachher andere sprache funktioniert da
weniger also nicht so ganz gut aber
geschichte ist auch eine aller dinge
okay er ist es möglich also wenn man
deutsch lernt diese fälle deklination
ist es möglich dass also 100% zu
nominieren ist es möglich wenn man
spricht alle diese fälle immer also
genau zu fördern
meiner meinung nach ja bei den artikeln
ist es ein bisschen ein anderes thema
die sind echt gemein aber ich bin der
meinung dass man die zelle beherrschen
kann
ich sage nicht dass es einfach ist also
ich muss ja selber die fälle auf
russisch habe ich ja auch lernen müssen
und ich weiß aus eigener erfahrung
selbst wenn man weiß wie es richtig ist
manchmal rutscht es einem einfach raus
aber ich glaube wenn man wie gesagt sich
viel mit deutsch auseinandersetzt viel
deutsch hört liest uns selber spricht
und dabei darauf achtet was ist denn
jetzt richtig und also die regeln kennt
dann kann man es mit übungen glaube ich
immer richtig machen also ich kenne auch
leute die das problemlos immer richtig
hinbekommen selbst wenn sie noch artikel
fehler machen
ich bin der meinung dass die vorzüge
naja und außer geschlecht geschlagen
geschlecht aber kennst du ausländer in
deutschland die deutsch sprechen ohne
fehler
ja tatsächlich ja jetzt muss man immer
unterscheiden wenn die leute natürlich
schon als kinder nach deutschland
gekommen sind
aber ich kenne auch ich kenne auch ein
paar bedeute die die als erwachsene
hergekommen sind und tatsächlich ab wo
man ab und zu vielleicht mal ein
bisschen akzent hat aber generell es ist
super also man kann es kaum merken
und ja die meisten leute machen glaube
ich für immer zumindest manchmal noch
artikel oder halt geschlechter zähler
und das ist auch finde ich also
verständlich und ich finde es auch
normal wenn man eine sprache als
erwachsener lernt und dann einen kleinen
akzent behält ich selber bin da immer
sehr
jetzt fällt mir selber ein deutsches
wort nicht ein englisches also ich
möchte immer irgendwer gut danke ich bin
immer sehr sehr ehrgeizig möglichst gut
also wirklich möglichst akzentfreie zu
sprechen
das ist mir wichtig ob es klappt weiß
ich nicht aber es gibt aber aber ich
glaube man kann sehr gut ein
fremdsprache beherrschen fast gewachsen
was bist fehler aber es wird immer
irgendwo etwas ist ja nicht so dass es
nicht zu sagen dass es nicht schlecht
das ist nicht schlecht aber wir sagen
auch englisch die you won't be taking
the native die du wirst nicht einenge
für euch durch einige sekunde einige
minuten werde es aber diese leute spielt
also das wie ein engel
aber irgendwo wird es etwas also ich
glaube dafür nicht immer stimmt ich
glaube dass es meistens ist aber also
aus meiner eigenen erfahrung wenn ich in
den usa bis ich erwähne das ich aus
deutschland bin denken die leute ich bin
muttersprachlerin meistens denken sie
ich bin irgendwo aus dem mid west oder
aus kanada keine ahnung wieso wirkung
wenn ich ein wenig in england bin denken
sie also da kommen mir mehr leute auf
die schliche also da ich erkennen mehr
leute das ist keine amerikanerin bin
aber grundsätzlich hast du glaub ich
recht dass es sehr sehr schwer ist und
man braucht sehr sehr sehr viel los ist
kann sein aber das doch nicht die
hauptziele seien und man muss diese
sprachen genießen spaß haben und dann
werde man immer ein bisschen akzentfrei
zu sein ist nicht das ziel
es ist schön aber es ist nicht das
wichtigste ok danke schön kanns ja das
war sehr interessant und jetzt den ich
motivierenden motivieren dennoch
motiviert motiviert noch einmal ja super
das freut mich auf video heraus werde
also diese link zu sein
youtube kanal in meiner wir sagen klar
zum ändern des hübschen beginn der
beschreibung zusätzlich schreibe
schreibe okay vielen dank
[Musik]